بعد اكثر من عامين على بدء تدريسها للطلاب
اختياريا تزداد اعداد الطلاب الراغبين في
تعلم اللغه الصينيه علهم يستخدمونها سواء
خلال زياراتهم للصين او للدراسه فيها
مستقبلا يوجد اقبال متزايد من طلاب
المرحله الثانويه على تعلم اللغه الصينيه
في
المقرر الاختياري الذي يتم ادراجه لهم من
ضمن المنهج هناك ايضا اهميه كبيره لتدريس
اللغه الصينيه بالنسبه للطلاب والطالبات
الطلاب والطالبات يقومون بتعلم لغه جديده
في سن مبكر هذا بالتاكيد له اثر كبير على
تعزيز
وتنميه مهارات التواصل هناك ايضا فرصه لهم
للاطلاع على ثقافه اخرى
في اللغه الصينيه او طريقه تدريسها في
المدارس هي ماده اختياريه او ماده حره
يسجل فيها الطالب عندما يكون عندها الرغبه
او الشغف للتعلم مثل ما انت عارف هي لغه
جديده رموز جديده
طالب يحب يتعلم كيف هذه الرموز كيف
الكلمات كيف راح يتكلم باللغه الصينيه
خمسه اسابيع كانت كفيله بتعلم تركي
المشاري الطالب في المرحله الثانويه
اساسيات اللغه الصينيه التي اختار دراستها
للتعرف اكثر على ثقافات الصينيين ويبدو
انه يبلي حسنا فقد نجح بفهم اساسيات اللغه
خلال فتره وجيزه
اول شيء نبدا باول جمله
مشاري انا عارف باسمي واسمي تركي خالد
المشاري ممتاز الثانيه
وهذا عمري 18 سنه والجمله الثالثه
يعني انا اكون طالب العلاقات السعوديه مع
الصين تتقدم يوما بعد يوم ومثل ادراج
اللغه الصينيه في المناهج الدراسيه بالم
خطوه مهمه تجاه تعزيز هذه العلاقه باعتبار
ان تعلم اللغه الصينيه يعد جسرا يزيد
الروابط السياحيه والثقافيه بين شعبي
السعوديه والصين من الرياض نواف عزيز
العربيه